what's going on this is Troy it's Rashad
and we are earned your leisure yes and
check us out on the bootleg Kev podcast
we talk about investing we talk about
rap we talk about fashion we talk about
everything man it's a dope episode check
it out yeah tap in
bootleg cat podcast I've been watching
these guys for a very long time I feel
like that they are spearheading a really
dope movement of financial literacy in
the hip-hop community and uh communities
of color and just younger Generations
I've learned a lot from y'all man we got
to earn your leisure podcast in the
building what's going on what up what up
what up what's good uh first things
first how did y'all link up
um we grew up together so um
he's two years older than me so uh I was
in sixth grade and he was in eighth
grade and at the time there was a
remember this movie Eddie uh yeah Whoopi
Goldbergs
um they had extras and so they they took
a group of kids from our neighborhood
and we went to Madison Square Garden and
we were extras in the movie we actually
never made the Final Cut but it was
pretty dope experience to be on a movie
set so
I was always hanging around with older
kids my whole life
um so everybody knew me because I was a
different school but I didn't know him
because he was new to the neighborhood
so um we were all there and I was always
kind of like introverted so I just
stayed to myself so everybody was
talking to me and he came over and he
just like was talking to me like he
already knew who I was and I'm like who
is this why is he talking to me like so
that's the first time that we met on
this set of a movie
um I was like 12 he was probably like
14. and yeah we just been friends ever
since you've been rocking ever since
yeah yeah yeah what was like for me
because like well this is a random curve
because you guys were an Eddie
I do have a random when I watch these
basketball movies that get filmed and
there's like real NBA players in them
and like people in the crowd I always
wonder if they go in and they like pause
a game oh yeah no and they're like all
right guys this is for a movie or do
they like do a whole fake game it's a
whole so like what happened was they
took us to the garden and they let us go
on the court and like if we made a shot
there was people in the crowd they would
chill but it would be cheering for us
and so then obviously they would cut in
between live footage of real games okay
but the the audience reaction would be
actually us on the court that was the
first time we actually got paid for
anything were any of the Knicks actually
there so what's so funny is that they
weren't in the movie but we we were in
the garden so they had a game that day
so we were seeing as we were like
wrapping up the shoot we saw some of the
Knicks come in yeah what's the era here
is this like Charlie Ward like this is
Charlie
Allen Houston Davis I saw him come off
and they were
um if I get the daycare they were
playing the Pistons wow so it was like
Grant Hill was coming to the Garden so
you know what's so crazy is that now
forget this Hubert Davis walks in right
and it's a group of us and um like we
was like little kids like 12 13 years
old so we've seen Huber Davis like
Hubert what's up man because like can we
get your autograph
and he just looked and just kept and
kept walking and he's not the guy I
think we might walk him to him that's
why Jordan would be killing you or
something like that that's why no one's
that's why Mitchell we're making your
jersey well and I just it's just crazy
because it's like you know 20 years
later and I still remember that so it's
you got to be careful how you treat
people because you never know right and
it's like that's something that even now
to this day we try to you know
accommodate people the best thing that
we possibly can and if we can't
accommodate it we'll try to like let you
know why we can't do this and we got to
catch a flight we gotta go I never
forget like we was little kids and we
saw him and he was not interested in
stopping at all as a kid I had great
experiences with some NBA players
but there was two one of them it's okay
because it was Charles Barkley he was an
[__] outside of a Cardinals game
but the other guy George mccloud's bum
ass from the sons
you remember George McLeod like a fake
3-and-d guy before 3 and D was a thing
[__] George McLeod he was
um yeah it's crazy because like you guys
obviously now are you know I feel like
when it comes to like financial literacy
like I think of you guys in the same
vein as I think of a guy like garyvee or
even more educational though obviously
like I feel like you guys are giving out
so much information and I've really
leveled up the last few years is it like
you know you guys probably go out and
get recognized get stopped all the time
at this point right yeah yeah pretty
pretty often man it's uh it's something
you get adjusted to right um but it's
not easy at first right when you walk
around and we're from New York so we
just got the New York State of Mind like
yo they looking at me and then you
realize like oh wait they're looking at
me because of the things that we've done
but it's cool man everything has been in
rooted in education I'm glad that you
brought that up you said you know it's
more educational because it started in
the classroom for us yeah we're teaching
young kids about financial literacy then
obviously him as a professional doing it
for adults and then realizing you know
there's really no age limit to this
education we really need to give it to
everybody so it's one of those things
that you know no age limit outside of
the content game obviously you guys are
very successful in creating great
content with real substance
um what before you guys got into doing
this podcast
what was like your guys's main sources
of income
I was I was a teacher so I was a middle
school teacher I taught health and phys
Ed
um the PE guy I was a p the you know the
number one place that kids love to go oh
yeah yeah for sure yes I had a great man
only until I got into the classroom I'm
like what am I doing here right but it
helped me man help me with with
structure helped me with lesson planning
and it also helped me see what was being
taught to kids and like after I saw like
my classroom teachers I'm just like yo
what are we teaching these kids like
they're not going to use any of this and
that was kind of the thing that spawned
me like yo There's an opportunity to
teach kids things that are going to be
actual in the future financial literacy
being one of them and so it kind of
became the thing was like yo if I'm
gonna get paid for this I'd rather be a
service than a disservice and so we had
an opportunity in the summer to create a
program and during the program we're
going to pay the kids based on how they
perform their their internships and it
was 500 which is a lot for a 14 year old
and it was like yo if we don't teach
them the value of money and the things
you can do with it and how it could be
used as a tool
um it's going to be the same cycle and
so I was like yo if we give them
information now let's see what they'll
be at in the future and so education and
like I said has always been the rule a
route for me and it cuts through what
about you I was a financial advisor so
you were kind of helping same same type
of vein what I was doing now what I am
doing now
um so yeah helping people with their
finances investing Insurance retirement
planning and uh that's kind of how I had
the idea to go on social media because I
saw that there was a need for it I saw
the Gap I saw how little people knew
about Finance even very educated people
doctors lawyers they didn't know about
yeah the basics when it comes to
investing so it's like all right vast
majority of people in this world need
the information and social media
was and is the I think the best way to
reach the masses and that was the idea
was like all right let's really double
down on social media and use this as a
platform
to you know spread the message yeah I I
mean even me as like a semi or
successful guy up until maybe like four
or five years ago when I really started
watching y'all [__] like I feel like I
learned how to like really leverage my
credit and leverage credit cards in your
favor through you guys like a lot of
[__] I was not doing you know what I
mean like that I'm like oh [__] there's
like and like I know that there's some
states I think there was a state that
might have been Florida I don't want to
give rotten to Santa's too much credit
but I think Florida might be introducing
financial literacy as a yeah Florida New
Jersey it's like 20 something States now
that have
um mandated financial literacy is still
not in New York where we're from so not
in the majority of States but there are
more and more States that's looking to
implement that yeah for you guys
um you know we're kind of in a weird
place in in terms of the economy because
like we just got out of this like you
know this thing that didn't make sense
and that was coveted and somehow during
a pandemic everything shot through the
roof
the real estate [__] was insane like
this isn't real I kept telling everybody
guys there's no way this is real like
and I bought a house you know I took
advantage of that interest rate and I
don't plan on selling it for a very long
time so I you know I made that decision
kind of knowing that you know
I might lose some Equity but it'll be
all right in the long run but what do
you like like the real estate Market's
kind of crazy right now a lot of places
are finally kind of correcting like um
what did you guys take away from the
pandemic because there was a lot of hard
assets that shot through the roof that
are correcting now like did you guys
learn anything personally about
any because you guys you know we look at
you as like you know but I feel like
there was a lot of wild [__] going on
from 2020 to now tons of it yeah
um I think one of the things we stood by
was like there's always opportunities in
crisis like in the crisis and so 2008
there was a crisis and it was like damn
we didn't have the capital to take
advantage of it but we were in Prime
position at this point to say all right
the market is pulled back you know
there's an opportunity to invest in
things you said one of the good things
was real estate right like interest
rates were at two and a quarter and it
was like wait this is an opportunity to
refinance so this is an opportunity to
use a HELOC these things were we were
educated on so it was like all right
we're in proposition to to take
advantage of it but not only us it was
like yo what if our community understood
that they could use it to their
advantage and so during that time we
created uh you know our show Market
Mondays which is about Stock Investing
and it took off because people were
listening to it they were getting the
information and they were actually
applying it you guys are doing that like
live on Zoom yeah live every Monday it
was like Wow people are actually seeing
with positive returns and was like oh
this is incredible yeah and there's one
thing like when you give people
information is one thing right but when
you give them information and it puts
money in their pocket it becomes totally
different it's like a totally different
relationship now it's like wait I have
to come back in fact when I come back I
got to tell my friends about it because
this is legit
um and so we was always rooted in the
education of it but when people started
applying it was like all right it took
it to a different level yeah the HELOC
thing I did something I just recently
learned about too uh and we could break
it down with that is it's obviously uh
is that that's that's a line of credit
yeah you can take out against your house
right yeah home equity line of credit um
and it's crazy because p people was
using that to their advantages was like
like you said you had equity in your
home you could take it out you can use
it to for repairs you can use it a lot
of people are trying to use it for other
Investments or you could just can't you
take it out without touching it and then
it's there if you need it right yeah
exactly and then what happened when we
started getting educated around it
people started taking advantage of it
Banks started realizing and they were
like all right well we're going to stop
ordering this product crazy right
because it was like oh this is the
opportunity that people could use to
their advantage
um and so it's one of those things like
when you have the education and the
timing of situations happen you got to
be prepared for it you got to be ready
to take action because again if you
don't they can pull the plug and say all
right well it was a great opportunity
but you're going to miss this one do you
guys feel like this like kind of time
that we're getting into with a lot of
the uh you know real estate kind of
correcting obviously the interest rates
are higher but do you feel like it's a
it's it's soon I mean it's it's kind of
getting to be about not not a
not a seller's market a buyer's market
you would think that that's coming soon
do you feel like there's going to be
some dope opportunities to
scoop real estate for a lot cheaper than
I mean obviously than a year and a half
ago you know [__] was crazy there's
always opportunities it's just hey it
depends geographically where you're at
right so
the LA Market is a lot different from
Milwaukee yeah where like right now you
could probably buy a home in Milwaukee
for thirty thousand dollars forty
thousand dollars you buy a building for
fifty thousand dollars right where you
can't even buy a closet for fifty
thousand dollars in LA right so there's
always opportunities it's just a matter
of a knowing where the opportunities are
um but be is it going to be a massive
correction
I don't think it'll be a massive
correction right um it'll probably be
some pullbacks in areas like Miami or
you know certain parts of New York like
where the real estate went up a lot yeah
I saw like Phoenix Austin like like a
lot of those hot markets where things
just got really crazy I feel like
they're gonna probably yeah I mean it's
the number one rule of investing no
matter whether it's Dogecoin whether
it's Tesla stock whether it's Miami real
estate what goes up must come down for
sure that's just like the most basic way
to think about anything in life and when
things start to not make sense
eventually it's going to start to cool
off very soon so like when you hear
Miami people paying over 500 000 over
asking and uh uh a quarter million
dollars over asking it buying things in
cash like they just got so so crazy the
last couple of years
it has to pull back eventually because
it's just not sustainable that's what
happened in Phoenix like uh everybody
sold their houses here because [__] was
at all time high and they didn't care
going to a city like Phoenix that
they're moving to and they're the houses
are so much cheaper they're like oh I'll
pay 100 over that's still like I'm still
getting a mini mansion from where I was
just coming from and I still have
pocketed a few hundred thousand dollars
so yeah we'll see man on the crypto
front
um where like how do y'all feel about
crypto now because obviously a lot of
[__] has crashed
I've lost some money for sure not as
much but I lost money in 2017 pretty
badly because this [__] guy convinced
me to buy all this Ripple yeah whatever
and you didn't sell it when you had all
that money anyway
um but how do you guys feel about like
kind of like obviously because I kind of
look at crypto as like similar to like
the.com
bubble that happened
um you know there was a lot of
low hanging fruit scam [__] going on but
I do feel like like the technology of
blockchain is something that
will probably be around and be you know
a utility for a long time to come but
what do you how do you all feel about it
I think crypto is here the idea of
blockchain technology is very real it
has very real use cases it is actually
being used right now
um the functionality and the purpose of
crypto still has to kind of be worked
out I feel like
um it's not something that is really
necessary right now like they still have
to kind of figure out because even if
you look at Bitcoin which is the most
popular cryptocurrency most people are
looking at that as a store of value
they're not looking at it the word
currency is a little misleading because
it's not being used as currency it's not
it's being important they're parking
their money yeah it's more of an
investment or you're just hoarding it
right hoping that it goes up in value
nobody's going to the store and pulling
out their Bitcoin card and shopping at
Target yeah and and it's it's in order
for currency to be used it has to be
some level of stability like I can't get
my hair cut today for twenty dollars and
then go back tomorrow and it's 50 and
then the next week is ten dollars like
doesn't make sense and that's how
that's how volatile cryptocurrency is so
right now we're in a winter for crypto
but historically crypto has always had
these Cycles where it's going up and
then it's going down then it's going up
and it's going down so if history
repeats itself it will go up again but I
think it's important to to Really you
know if you're going to invest in
cryptocurrency use coins that
um have a strong chance of surviving so
ethereum
Bitcoin you said xrp different things in
that nature where it's like a lot of
these meme coins like the Dogecoin and a
bunch of these other coins it was just
like a get rich quick scheme it wasn't
really based around any fundamentals it
wasn't based around any use case it was
just based around all right let's just
pump this coin yeah everybody had a coin
my friend who's sitting to the right of
me
yeah he thought it was a great idea to
invest in a coin that Willie D from the
Ghetto Boys was spearheading
the Willie D Coin and I was like what
was the clinical
and I was like is he from Houston I was
like I was like
Willie D Willie D a legend yeah for sure
shout out to them yeah well you lost all
your money yeah I think I mean you said
it best I think when you compared it to
the.com it makes it's a good analogy
yeah right but the key is right when
the.com bubble started you had aols
United excite.com
right but you also have Yahoo and you're
at Amazon it's about figuring out which
one is going to have the long-term
sustainability and as we get further
inside the space of cryptocurrency and
they'll be better and more improved
coins obviously you spoke about the two
most prevalent ones but you know Google
comes to that 2006. or YouTube comes in
2006 right so there's an evolution
that'll happen and it'll become more of
a use case scenario and it'll be more
improved but it's not going anywhere
right we've seen it since 2012. you
mentioned 2017. we felt that pain too
right we have money in the space and
didn't take it out I should have sold
though
but it's one of those things if we're
looking at it as a short-term investment
or a long-term investment and so we tend
to look at things in the long term right
so it's a space that we'll be in and
we're going to stay in right for you
guys um we all like I always hear like
people say like uh you you want to have
a diverse portfolio of Investments right
there's real estate there's the stock
market there's hard assets like what
would be your guys's advice in terms of
like how that should be broken up
yeah um yeah you definitely want to
diversify I mean as far as real estate
at the very least you should try to own
where you live
um that's it like a goal that you can at
least try to achieve and some people
some people who are like really rich say
the opposite they like have investment
properties but they rent where they went
right yeah well another thing is that
for the average person you can own a
multi-family home right so it's like
because that idea is that your home
isn't really an investment and if you
look at it from that standpoint where
it's not actually bringing you cash flow
then that's true right but if you have a
multi-family home and I don't know if
there's a lot of multi-families in
California but I know there are actually
yeah so if you if you have a
multi-family now that is an investment
that is bringing you cash flow and
potentially can be you know you could be
making money on that as opposed to just
shuffling money out every single month
just to pay the mortgage so that's a
that's a good way to even start just
your Investment Portfolio right like as
far as for the average person if you
just want to start investing in real
estate get a multi-family home as your
first investment live there now you
killed two birds live in one right and
rent out the other two units right so
now like I said you kill two birds with
one stone or if you're a business owner
now you can live upstairs and your
business could be downstairs right and
then you can rent the other place you
know if there's another unit as well so
um that's important and investing in the
stock market is important as well right
you want to have some money that's going
into stocks long term not necessarily
like day trading or taking risky bets
but you know we talk about index funds
and ETF stuff like that and then you
know it's important to say for your
retirement as well so if you have a job
a lot of jobs they offer 401K plans if
you're self-employed you can have an IRA
so now you have you know three different
things working for you you have your
retirement you have your regular stocks
you have your real estate plan right now
you developing a portfolio if you have
kids you might want to do a college
savings plan for them or utma which is
allowing you to put money into their
investment account so now you can start
to do some other things but those are
like the three three pillars I think as
far as investing is concerned for the
average person like real estate uh
investing in stocks just regular
brokerage and then retirement account so
like a retirement account like there's
so many different ones and this is
something that I'm still like uh I mean
obviously had a 401k for a long time I
just rolled into a IR array because I
don't work for anybody anymore but
um there's like uh the Roth IRA right
like can you guys kind of give me like a
breakdown of the differences between
those accounts some pay do some pay
dividends or so it depends on how you
invest it so like a IRA is an individual
retirement account and you could put six
dollar thing 65 in my raise it's like 6
500 for this year but you put money in
it and it lowers your taxable income so
if you put five thousand dollars into an
IRA you make a hundred thousand dollars
now you only pay taxes on ninety five
thousand so the money grows and you can
invest the money in a variety of
different ways so you can invest the
money in the s p you can invest the
money in Apple stock you can invest
their money in you know dividend paying
companies and have the dividends go back
into the investment account so it's
really up to you as far as how you
choose to invest it or who you're
working with invested for you right
um but the main benefit is the tax
benefit that's the difference between
just investing it just regular and
investing in IRAs that you get a tax
benefit then it was a Roth IRA which is
a retirement vehicle as well but you
don't get attacks benefit from it up
front so if you make a hundred thousand
you put five thousand into the raw if
you're still taxed on a hundred thousand
right but
when you take the money out in
retirement is tax-free so like when you
take money out of a retirement account a
401k or IRA you get you get taxed you
pay state and federal tax so if you have
a million dollars right and let's say
you take out the whole amount at one
time when you're 70 years old now you
know you pay federal tax but that'll put
you in the highest federal tax bracket
because it's treated like ordinary
income and then depending on what state
like if you live in California it's the
highest state taxes you could be paying
up to like 50 of the money in taxes so
if you take out a million you might net
a 500 000. crazy so but if you have a
Roth and you take out a million you
don't pay any taxes so you get one
million dollars
so the difference between a Roth and a
regular Ira is the tax benefits come one
is at the beginning one is at the end
correct yeah yep so if you're like
making decent money you're kind of like
[__] up if you're not doing a little
bit of both would that be fair
especially I mean within his income
limits too so it gets a little tricky
because then it's like all right if you
make too much money then well if you're
if you're in if you're self-employed you
can you can put money into an IRA no
matter how much money you make but if
you have a job and you make too much
money then his income limits debt
um you can't put money into an IRA so
now you that's why the 401K is
beneficial because you could put a lot
more money into a 401k right as opposed
you could put like three times more
money into a 401k than you could put
into an IRA yeah and then if you're
self-employed you could have what's
called a SEP IRA and you could put up
like sixty thousand dollars a year into
a SEP IRA what's the uh tax tax
situation with that it's the same you
get you get the tax benefits on the
front on the front on the front yeah
it's like a regular Ira but you just put
way more money in so if you have a SEP
IRA uh our IRA and let's say I make
three hundred thousand dollars and I put
50 in I'm taxed on 250. it's a
percentage of
is 20 of your income the the lesser of
20 or like sixty thousand dollars and
don't quote me on that but I think that
that's that's around
um what it is so
it's like a calculator to see like which
one which one is less it's less yeah
that but it allows you to put a lot more
money then it's like you know you have
the fine Benefit Plan you have pension
plan so these are all ways that you know
and this is why education is important
right because it's like the average
person is not they don't care about this
exactly right it's like who who cares
but if you're saving 300 000 a year or
you saving a hundred thousand dollars a
year you start to care right you know
you start to care it's like damn that's
a lot of money it's like this this
equals millions and millions of dollars
so now you see why the rich get richer
right because they're implementing these
strategies at a very high level so now
they they're figuring out how to save
millions of dollars how to pay no taxes
how to have real estate and how to
actually get money back from the
government because of you know different
incentives and you're talking about um
opportunity zones or different things in
that nature like there's so many things
that's put in place
for the educated and the wealthy to take
advantage of and then the middle class
and then the poor are just uneducated
and they're not financially in a
position to do anything so they never
really even think about it yeah so it's
it's almost like if you're self-employed
right and you're doing like let's say
you own a business or a laundromat or
whatever you're doing right there's so
there like we always hear how like
Donald Trump don't pay taxes or Google
doesn't pay taxes and
um there's so many things you can do
instead of writing a check to the IRS
that's the goal right you know I just
did this like historically my whole life
like no I drive like [__] I'm a terrible
driver and
I hate car payments
you could ask this guy I've just I've
been kind of like paid off Toyota my
whole life and then I crash and then I
get another paid off car but like I had
like a [__] crazy tax bill last year
and my CPA was like and this was like
end of November
and she was like hey
go find a [__] hundred thousand
dollar car so I went and bought a car
and I don't feel as bad about it now you
know because I was gonna either
pay the IRS or
drive a car you know yeah a truck or a
car it was a truck it was six thousand
pounds there we go yeah yeah I mean that
but this is education around we hear
these things and it's like like you just
said you spoke about the the Roth IRA
and 401K but even like he said
opportunity zones we just had these
terms and it's kind of like uh we never
know what that means right and then you
have to do the education behind it and
it's like all right well opportunity
zones how do we get that well you have
to have capital gains well how many of
us have a couple of games that are over
a million dollars right all right and
then you realize wait we can't even
participate there's a first education
but then you realize wait there's a
business structure that we're not even a
part of yet to even be considered to be
in this
um so the education part is the most
important you said what like the things
we shouldn't invest in
start investing in your education first
yeah right and then start building those
things that we were just talking about
excuse me and and thanks to you guys
like I mean I know you guys monetize
like what you do like I'm sure you guys
have courses and [__] but like you guys
are giving away all the game for free
that's why I love Russ is a rapper
I love Russ because Russ is like
these people don't like him but he's
really giving y'all the [__] crash
course of free games like selfless free
games same with the Russell you know
what I mean like these guys like and you
guys have the Russell on but like these
guys are like just giving away game and
you guys are giving away game you know
what I mean I think it's dope because I
see some guys
man there was this one dude
Tai Lopez
oh my God
Modell's right yes the cringiest dude on
the internet man and like he would be
doing these videos that pop up on my
[__] [__] we'd be like in front of
his Lamborghini do you want this sign up
and like it's just dope that I mean you
and and you guys aren't aren't the same
you guys are Edge I look at you as an
educational platform I look at guys like
that or garyvee is like motivational you
know yeah what do you guys think of uh I
saw you guys speak on this a little um I
didn't watch your guys's video on it but
the Grant Cardone situation
obviously Grant's successful
his book is cool but then once I started
to kind of see him on YouTube I was like
oh this guy's kind of a [__] Loki
respectfully like very successful guy
you know I get it his book is cool if
like if I if I read his book and didn't
hear how he talked you know what I mean
or like you know I'm like oh this guy's
like you know he's kind of a douchebag
but you know successful uh but there's a
lot being made of some of the uh older
clips
of him talking about how he talks to the
urban community
um when you guys see a guy like that as
as somebody who's in that Community
who's helping educate that Community
from a genuine place you know how do you
guys feel about that
um and I'm sure you guys already talked
about it because I saw the YouTube
videos I feel like it's a marketing
strategy right so it's like my whole
thing is like you don't have to be black
to be part of hip-hop culture like you
could be Asian you could be white you
could be Latino like you know but if
you're not a part of hip-hop culture I
don't understand the fascination with
trying to go over and above to try to
identify with something that you really
didn't grow up in you're not really
passionate about like I I don't think
he's listening to Rick Ross's mixtapes
like why are you hanging around Roy it's
like when we do it like it's from a
genuine place right like before we did
this like we would debate rap for hours
like we would debate basketball for
hours like this is just who we are like
we can't appropriate our culture we are
the culture right you know what I'm
saying like so but I feel like him and a
variety of other people they use hip-hop
culture as a way to gain
um notoriety
uh credibility in the space because
everybody knows like you know once
hip-hop stamp shoot like that means a
lot right and it it's like some things
are worth more than money so we don't
have the economic power but we have the
cultural capital and cultural capital is
extremely important and it's extremely
valuable so they see that from a
business standpoint they're like all
right well these rappers they've been
lit for years and they've they move look
what we did to fashion for instance
right so it's like from Tommy he'll
figure it out from Tommy Hilfiger to
Balenciaga to Gucci to Nikes anything
anything any any fashion that's lit it
has to be stand by there
let's take a high-end fashion because we
spoke with Dapper Dan so he was saying
like Gucci like hip-hop culture probably
makes up like five percent of the total
pie that makes Gucci right that's a
valid point but it makes up probably 95
of the influence of why they're buying
of why other people are buying it right
because it's become so popular so it's
just like Crystal
hip hop thing exactly so even if hip-hop
wasn't the number one source of Revenue
it became the number one source of
influence which made other people want
to buy it because it became so popular
so I think people in business have
adopted that same strategy where it's
like all right even if these aren't my
number one consumers I'm not gonna make
a tremendous amount of money with this
community
I can gain a lot of notoriety
from this community which would help me
make money with other communities so I
think that you know he's one of these
people that have adapt uh have adopted
that strategy and um you know it's it's
a business Ploy so it's it's up to us to
see how we feel about it if we accept it
or not but um I I just feel like it's
not from a genuine place when you do
things like that and like I said it's
not to say like you can't hang out with
rappers not to say you can't you know go
to an NBA game but if you if you're if
your goal is to embrace culture then you
looking at it like music is the only
part of the culture that's kind of
offensive right because it's like all
right like you're saying the only thing
that we bring to the table is
entertainment so if you really are truly
passionate about embracing our culture
then embrace all aspects of the culture
music is a part of it but so is social
justice right so it's economics right so
is science so is a variety of other
things and I never see these people
hanging out with political activists
I've never seen them hanging out with
you know leaders in business I never see
them hanging out with the young Tech
entrepreneur that's that's in HBCU
trying to get his startup company done I
only see him hanging out with rappers so
it becomes questionable as far as their
motivation yeah and it goes to the part
when he's saying like it's awareness
right like our job is like all right
let's make the people aware of what's
happening if they're not but they choose
to do with it it's going to be on them
right there's still people that are
gonna that champion but it was not
surprising we see like you said we've
seen this play plenty of times but the
problem was for so long we couldn't
quantify it how do we qualify the
influence right we can say like this is
the customer base because we can see the
sales but how do you quantify or Justify
the level of influence like we know it
right but from the business standpoint
it's like well the numbers don't match
that until you get a situation like
Kanye and Adida right and then you see
cultural capital cultural influence
remove both and let's see what happens
to the business and that's what they
happen they're going through right now
it's like well we just lost two billion
dollars yeah let's bring them back to
the table because we need to sell this
right can we come back can we can we
renegotiate how we're gonna again be
cool or appear cool to the community
that we know
got us to this level and have you say
it's okay to sell these things again if
not what are we going to do with all
this merchandise how are we going to
move it what's going to happen to our
brand what's going to happen to the
people that are existing on our brand if
that guy says like we're not rocking
with you and his core audience says
we're not rocking with you anymore which
is our culture yeah I think Kanye is
probably single-handedly like
the most influential
I mean irises I mean [__] I can't think
anybody's more influential in terms of
culture and fashion and like you know
he's obviously said some things that are
questionable reasons true but but man no
I mean he's the guy right he slams your
[__] it's up but he sets the standard
now right like yo there's the cultural
capital there's a cultural influence
together and look what happens now we
can quantify it now that there's
measurables to say like that happened
because this was removed and like it's
crazy because like when Yeezy first came
out everyone was like man these are hobo
clothes and the Earth Tones and [__] and
everybody's everybody's wearing the [__]
yeah let's talk about hip-hop guys let's
do it I don't want to I don't I mean
give me each one of your guys's top five
favorite albums favorite albums not MCS
because that's hip-hop rap boy rap rap
okay yeah
um for me my favorite album of all time
was it was written okay by Nas
affirmative action is one of my favorite
songs ever yeah it was written that
changed my life so it was written I
would go with that another album that
came change my life is the infamous by
Marvel yes
I remember I bet big noid in Tampa
I was just like bro give up the good you
know that's a classic verse oh my God
yeah sometimes I wish I had three
different faces shout out to Noy man
rest in peace to Prodigy for sure
um
I was I would speed it up to a little
current times Victory lap is definitely
a favorite of mine yes I think a very
classic album and has aged gracefully
gets better every time yeah I agree it's
up there
um I probably would go
life after death okay biggie
that's up there for me
and then
another album that
changed my life was Volume 2 from Jay-Z
that's probably my favorite Jay-Z album
that's an interesting favorite Jay-Z
album Choice yeah because for me it's
moments in time right so it's like
everybody's gonna say Illmatic is their
favorite Nas album but Illmatic I
appreciate it Illmatic I was 10 years
old but when it was written came out I
was 12 years old you don't really see
that much it's a big difference between
being 10 and 12. for sure so when I was
12 and it was like I was coming into
becoming a man and I could understand it
and and not it's real [__] like I'm
saying like you're coming to see a man
12 years old yeah
you're becoming a young adult so it's
like everything that he was just saying
it was just hitting me different and it
was like so the same thing with volume
two like I was in Middle School when I
came out and um I never forget like
everybody was playing that album and
that was like the album that changed
he sold five million records and it was
like
every song on that album is just dope
and the delivery and everything so it's
like that was a moment in time and that
was the the transition for Jay-Z because
we had new Jay-Z's for a long time as
far as his music was concerning now that
is the album that sparked the Hard Knock
Life tour yeah yeah that was that was
everything yeah he was never the same
after that album he was he became whole
yeah he became so thus that's my top
five hip-hop what about you top five
I'll change it because we got some of
the similar ones um Illmatic is my
favorite album of any genre of all time
okay
um I'm I'm there with you to that doggy
style for me but yeah I'm there yeah
yeah so like in in the studio we got the
albums like looking at us that doggy
style is definitely on there
um only Built for Cuba links
is in there life after death is is
definitely I think the greatest double
CD you ever made for sure
um better than ready to die too a lot
better
it is bad um he said the mob deep joint
so I I'll go I'll go with one of my
favorite guys of all time I'll say the
Carter 2 is one of my favorite albums of
all time Wayne is my guy I'm a die-hard
Wayne guy and then ah man there's a
couple that are super important
ah
if I have to if I have to is it it's j
but it's two I'm gonna go two for Jay I
think blueprint for J and four foot four
um is one of my favorite albums just
because of the growth right like we had
we saw some of our rappers not make it
to adulthood right to fatherhood to to
fully mature so to watch him from
Reasonable Doubt
to get to volume one volume two
obviously blueprint and then to grow and
have transgressions and have life
experience and to express that plus the
financial literacy piece inside of it
sure tons of tons of jams it's like kind
of the first like successful like
grown-up it's a yeah like grown man rap
battle like NASA life is good and it was
like oh that's growth that's fatherhood
we're experiencing these things at the
same time and like now he's talking
about financial literacy and 444 and
he's talking about marriage and he's
talking about like real grown man [__]
and Legacy and we're going through those
things in real life and I'm like yo this
is probably one of my favorite pieces of
work that he's ever done so those are my
five and if we had to count Lauren
Hill's miseducation we throw that in it
yeah I mean yo yeah you guys I I would
uh
volume two four four four those I mean
you know I always say about Jay-Z is
like there's a couple of Jay-Z albums
that I just did not like Magna carter
Holy Grail was one that just kind of he
tried to advance this in the art World
on that one we wasn't ready got a
[__] Samsung
nickels and dimes are still
we we forgive him for that one and um
the album that people dislike that I
love is blueprint too
because they kind of took all the best
songs and they but that Meet the Parents
is so amazing great song so good man
great song even like The Blueprint 2
record that blueprint or that uh just
boys produce with like the
with the flutes and [__] oh yeah that
[__] is crazy he was it was like the
last time you took shots at NAS yeah
yeah that [__] was hard because
yes because you don't understand and it
don't mean to be nice it's been dope to
see you guys
um interviewing artists now and I think
you guys are interviewing artists from
like a way
like I I love the perspective when you
guys talk to someone like the Russell or
Rick Ross like for you guys like kind of
going from being like a
and I mean you guys are still
independent but you guys obviously have
uh
blown up and you guys are doing dope
[__] now with revolt and doing all you
guys are doing a lot of cool [__] like
how cool is it to be able to interview a
guy like Rick Ross and have
conversations with these guys that you
guys grew up listening to notice it's a
real moment like you know as far as
three fans before anything for sure
listening to music growing up and
arguing having debates having fights
about music like you know I have I used
to have almost physical fist fights
about Nas and Jay-Z and during that time
and I [__] was team Nas so hard and I
just refused to listen to Jay-Z for
about a year so it's like so now that I
have Dame Dash on speed dial it's crazy
like you know what I'm saying like it's
not even a surreal moment and it's just
like Rick Ross like being in his house
and chopping it up with him like no I'm
saying like having conversations with
trt I was one of my favorite rappers of
all time talking to T.I like trap music
urban legend or King where are you at
all of them okay you got to pick one
trap music to me because that's set to
Vibe he changed and he's got that doing
my job on there was that a Yankee I
think that was a Kanye it wasn't doing
my job I feel like from a musical
standpoint he got into his his bag with
urban legend and the King album
Urban Legend's probably my favorite
album but trap music I mean he created
trap music he said it he's the first
person to say trap music so like that
alone is Hall of Fame status she would
just leave this boozy thing alone uh I
saw a video last night at him at his
restaurant on the mic holding up
paperwork and I was like yeah you know
what somebody said somebody they were
talking to us the other day I think it
was Big Boy it was like um
you live long enough to tell people to
hate you they start to see flaws in you
they start to say oh yeah yeah your
music is whack and it's unfortunate
right because it's like
the longer you live the more
opportunities you have to [__] up to be
discriminated yeah because you're under
the if you're as famous as T.I yeah
you're famous tips I got man he's a he's
a close friend of the show
um I think one of the funniest things he
said is like I don't I don't like
somebody that get Fly and then get shot
like yo don't don't talk crazy and then
not show up when they're invited to to
prove or to try to describe me and not
you know come to to see what is actually
true I just think like certain [__]
should be like the tip tips out there
you know TI I think is like he's TI yeah
exactly don't even acknowledge this [__]
like just keep it moving your tip bro
like you're one of the ghosts I was like
it's crazy man I mean that's what I'm
saying like we hip hop babies like I
would like I'm literally like a hip hop
baby born in South Bronx
grew up listening to Rakim and KRS up
until this point now where it's like
obviously you heard the list of people
that we named in our albums like getting
to meet Nas and him telling us that he
listens to what we're doing like like
think about the Nostalgia that it's just
like one of these moments in life you
like you know this is real like this guy
we listened to Growing Up and helped
shape and mold some of the things and
how we saw life right it's not listening
to us for what we do in education in the
financial space it's like pretty crazy
like even like the way we look at Jay
and being able to be at the Rock Nation
brunch it's like crazy right like this
is real life that's the kind of [__] you
see on Instagram every year it's like
yeah you see it and now you're there and
like you know we looked up like we
watched these guys like we'd watch Puff
and now to no puff and sit with him and
him tell us how important the work we're
doing is like it's not something you can
write in a script it's just like kind of
surreal because we're living these
moments but we have a reverence for
these people you know what I'm saying
like like you said tip is this guy and
like like we we argue all the time he's
like yo I used to say your Wayne's the
best rapper alive and he's like not tips
the best to do for himself I'm like nah
and now there's no tip and like he's
like know this guy thought Wayne was
better than you
at the time I did hey we got to
interrupt the interview man hey shout
out to my bookie man make sure you go to
mybookie.ag NFL season it's over but at
my bookie the opportunities to win
they're not over baby they don't stop
ever all right whether you want to make
some extra or just make the games more
exciting my book is going to give you
the most for your money with their
deposit bonuses now listen if you sign
up right now go to mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg you're gonna get a
welcome bonus up to a thousand dollars
and on top of that March Madness is on
the way ladies and gentlemen that's
right that college basketball tournament
is coming they're going to give you a
free hundred and fifty thousand dollar
March Madness bracket contest entry
imagine if you win 150 Grand you have to
put no money up crazy you gotta go to
mybookie.ag sign up with that promo code
bootleg right now thousand dollar
deposit bonus if you put a thousand and
they're gonna give you another thousand
all right and of course so much to bet
on what my you could do NCAA NBA NHL UFC
boxing what Jay is Jake Paul gonna win I
don't know but you could you could put
some money on Jake Paul I would all
right of course they also got their
weekly online Blackjack tournaments so
much roulette I mean slots so much with
so many Brands to choose from trust my
bookie I've been rocking with them for
over 10 years God damn it and they're so
easy to get your money out of so easy to
make money with they got the best like
simplest platform to use the best props
man trust me bet anything anytime
anywhere
with my bookie mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg sign up also shout out to our
family at hardean Jardine Las Vegas Yes
you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with
Jardine you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas you know what's so
funny is I do that [__] to my friends
all the time like if I get around a
famous person I'm with one of my
childhood friends I'm like like for
example common right my my best friend
has a great album so this is a classic
be in Resurrection yes uh but my best
friend his he always says his like I
know his top five albums right so we're
on Commons tour bus
and I'm like hey you have his third
favorite album of all time and he's like
third
what are the other two
he loves Resurrection but he thinks
Aquemini is much better that's another
classic I got it right there I got it
it's on my wall too yeah so I got that
oh man love equipment hey who's the goat
from the Bronx I'm gonna listen if I'm
forgetting it's got to be careless Fat
Joe or pun right yes it's um I'll say
this it's it's Fat Joe because of the
longer Big Pun KRS is the Pioneer and
he's he's always Gonna Be The Godfather
right Big Pun was the lyrical assassin I
mean Big Pun is the best rapper he's the
best rapper he didn't have a long enough
Fat Joe
Fat Joe is one of the most underrated
people in hip-hop history because I say
it all the time he came out in 92 yeah
and he's still relevant he's more
relevant now than he never was for sure
not even just from rapping just from a
personality standpoint we just love like
he's like he's like kind of like the
East Coast Snoop kind of yeah you know
we just love him when you see him you
know he's like 30 years in the game and
he's just as relevant now as he ever was
and he has a lot of hit records and he's
a beast of a rap like he's an MC's MC
is [__] verse on like big L's album
like man fat Joe's one of those guys
that joke I chose the one KRS
um yeah it's got to be Fat Joe for a
while like even through Middle School
people ask me who the best rapper was I
would tell you KRS
um but like you said it's a longevity
yeah and those guys it's it's
unfortunate because they're not the
thing is like like the Pioneers they're
not that much older than some of the
guys we hold in deep reference like you
said Fat Joe came out in 92 Fat Joe The
Gangster like Pedro's A og bro LL Cool J
and Jay-Z are not far in age right they
might be a three year age difference but
we look at them very differently when we
talk about the hip-hop cardi B's up
there it's because she's probably I
didn't even think of cardi yeah she's
the most she's the most commercially
successful artist to ever come out of
French French tool
I think French you got to put French as
far as like as we're talking about
commercial success in singles and music
that's dominated you got a diamond
record now cardi has two Diamond records
Cardi's way more musically no I'm saying
we gotta put them in a conversation for
the Bronx that's fair yeah if we're
talking lyrics if you're putting a five
together yeah Remy got to be in there
we're talking just lyrics
um but yeah you gotta you got to match
your friends as far as commercial
success that's the best album though
is capital punishment
or from the Bronx
invasion of privacy
let's go that's a great album that cardi
B album was great I came in front that
[__] was good I'm a guy that was great
historically like I don't relate to a
lot of women's like music you know but
that cardio almost crazy
she's a historical figure when it comes
to hip-hop already she's done so much
with and it's like she only has one
album that's it I mean she has a mixtape
[__] but like if we're thinking like
since like the world is known cardi
invasion of privacy and a bunch of bunch
of hits she's held the whip she's held
away for like eight years now like she's
held the throne and she's like he held
it for a long time yep shout out to
Nikki you're gonna hit another New
Yorker I'm just saying I don't know it
could be longer than I don't know but uh
that was like 2018 2017 late 2017. yeah
she won the Grammy in 2019. so what six
years okay six years so she's she's been
the number one female artist for six
years Nicki Minaj had it for a long time
and then cardi took it yeah I think the
difference between like I think cardi is
like probably the most in my opinion
like likable Personality yeah like
people just relate she's hilarious like
I I she got a McDonald's meal right now
yeah like I booked the offset at my club
for Super Bowl weekend and I went to the
Airbnb to drop off his money and like he
was playing me his album and [__] she
just came out of the bedroom she's she
was she's like the nicest girl yeah I
mean Super like super personable you
know I mean she has that yeah her
personality is is infectious like we we
saw that personality on Love and Hip-Hop
until obviously we both like the other
that [__] matters too because like if
you think about Fat Joe yeah if tomorrow
it came out that Fat Joe was hosting
Good Morning America we'd be like that's
crazy but we'd also be like I see it
good yeah yeah he's great he can do it
all the other person and we know him
personally so we just we actually just
had a two-hour debate with him at in
Utah
her All-Star we we ran into him and Fab
it was random at this restaurant and we
had a two-hour debate with Joe
about music
and yeah he's a very he's a very he's a
very opinion what was what was his why
because I've gotten into arguments with
Fat Joe about rap too what what was the
opinion he was he was standing on
I don't want to say too much
you know what Joe is he has a great
memory but some things the 50 list with
that and then he wasn't he wasn't about
that was he on the top 50 he was not in
the list that's egregious he was arguing
about himself which he said he should
have been on there but some of the
people on the list I will name I will
let them remain nameless but he was
confused about some of the people on the
list yeah I was confused by some of the
people I was confused about it I'm
confused by a lot of the people on the
list and he never was saying like I
should be on it he was just confused why
some people were on it um but he
definitely should be on it obviously
what we just said and uh we had a
spirited debate about the longevity of
people's careers and and what makes him
legendary
um and so like again like he's one of
those guys he just said 30 years like
some of these people that have made the
list maybe had two songs and we can't
remember a memorable verse or song
um and so it's interesting man the
people that make these lists we don't
know who they are who the [__] is
it was billboard and Vibe put together
and that's what it was yeah we don't
know who did it but my thing was like yo
let's why don't we create something
where we have people who we
agree uh valid enough and qualified
enough to make an opinion on this unless
like get 10 people in a room and make a
list that makes sense I saw it when I
saw
no when I saw Rick Ross was number 50.
okay that's what I know the list was
invested it's funny because I did a list
remember a few years ago somebody put
out their list of favorite like top
rappers and it went viral I forget who
did it so I did my own list and I had
Rick Ross at 10 which people were like
you're [__] crazy he's at least top
20. oh my gosh he's top 20. he's got a
classic a couple he's got a classic
which one are you saying this classic I
think Teflon Don is the one everyone
should agree on but I think Deeper Than
Rap Deeper Than Rap for my fingers like
Deeper Than Words One to me and it's a
classic to me no it's a classic well I
always tell everybody like there's like
Classics to us and then there's like
consensus classes change the game though
yeah definitely you can't win against 50
and that's when he he became a
mainstream Superstar artist but I think
there's like two classifications of
Classics I think there's like the
consensus Classics that like nobody
would disagree with the cult classic
doggy style get rich or die trying good
kid Mad City like there's no like if
anybody who knows hip-hop can't say [__]
if you say My Beautiful Dark twister
fantasy is a classic right they don't
yeah but then I think there's like
there's there other kind of like that's
why I always say Drake has Classic
Albums to me which one I like take care
and I like Nothing Was the Same oh my
God yeah
I think Drake's I think Drake's best
album I don't even know if it is an
album the mixtape if you're reading this
it's too late yes yeah like nothing was
the same as the best body Nothing Was
the Same as mine if you read this and
it's too late
every song on there like I don't go back
it's just tainted to me because I heard
the Clinton Miller references
I'm rocking with that I'm just using the
back end of that album running through
the six kind of like whoa like that was
that was the one to me but but I always
say that Drake is a an artist who has
yet to to have a consensus class he
doesn't have a classic like in in that
he doesn't have Illmatic he doesn't have
an Illmatic he doesn't have an equipment
I he doesn't have one of those now
there's an argument to be made to take
care it could be one of those but this
is an argument there's an argument
that's where I'm at with like and
[__] will swear that I'm bro I
was with Freddie Gibbs with this guy
I argued with Drake for about an hour
and a half about this in person the
first time I met him because I'm pretty
harsh on Drake but not like as a dick
because I'm a fan this [__] was
like oh I know exactly who you are and I
was like hey man
amen because I'm with my guys here I
gotta keep the same energy yeah I was
like
you know I just went viral recently
because I said you didn't have a classic
album so I just see it and he's like
well you know someone like you would
never understand
so we were arguing for it was at least
an hour
we're sitting at the bar at Harriet's in
West and I'm just explaining to him why
I don't like I'm like no you have a
classic I think Nothing Was the Same
it's a classic so why you say somebody
like you wouldn't understand because I'm
not from Toronto oh so he's like pretty
much looking at me like I'm some [__]
old head [__] backwards yeah yeah and
I'm like no I love your [__] yeah but
you gotta be a little more vulnerable
like I don't know Drake's like stance on
social issues yeah like you know what I
mean I wonder what he thinks his
Classics are yeah Drake doesn't from
that conversation did you get a sense of
like what he thought it went from that
and then we ended up and he owes me
fifty thousand dollars because we bet we
had an art then well we went into it we
went into this in this huge basketball
argument
um it was great it was great it was like
we walked away that night and it was one
of those nights I was like yo tonight
really happened like I argue with Drake
for almost two hours at a bar with
Freddie Gibbs about rapping NBA and he
bet me that year that my Phoenix Sons
would not go further than the Warriors
and that was the year we went to the
finals and lost to the Bucks 50 Grand oh
that's not that long did you ever act
support I haven't seen him
oh I definitely hit him did he read it
of course not if you read this we left
yeah I'm sorry I looked at
that was meant to lie right your album
cover that though everything the inside
of it the writing like people used to
tell stories I think good kid Mad City I
would say Victory lap too
um that's like the last album where it
really like because if you listen to
Victory lap and game actually did this
on the album too but the songs bleed
into each other so the the Beats
actually end up so like when you hit
like real big real big and then it's
like the other song well the song after
that um with CeeLo
they bleed into each other like you know
so it's like 40s minutes a day you know
who did a really good job of that
recently just side note Metro boomin's
album is [__] that's what I heard
it's crazy it's incredible yeah I think
them
the 40s mass at that yeah that that just
to transition from songs and even inside
the same song
I think I think the last classic of this
time like for this era I think my turn I
think little babies is the last classic
album I think time will tell yeah but
but this era but I feel like little
babies Essentials is the best Essentials
on Apple music but that's a different
conversation
randomly let me just throw this outfit
what what but what I'm saying is that
now it's become more about singles and
it's not really about a body of work
it's about
even if you have
15 songs it's like let's make 15 records
right they don't really have they're not
cohesive like good kid Mad cities
telling the story right it's not about
making a cohesive body of work it's just
about making songs right that sound good
some people we can't not Kendrick then
because that's what he just did I just
said Kendrick he's the last one yeah but
you said good command City but classic I
don't think that album that he put out I
don't think it's be known as a classic
butterfly I mean I think that's a
classic to me me too but it's a very
it's a cult class polarizing album I
love that album me too yeah and it aged
so good I love it I think Drake's gonna
have to just sit down and just say okay
this is a legacy I think so but I think
so Drake Drake has the ability to do a
legacy play where he just sits down and
says you know what I'm just going to
just make an album
he could make a concept album he could
put his head down give up The Alchemist
just blaze [__] but does he want to
though that's the thing that's why he
just did that I don't know if y'all saw
the whole little yachty interview but he
was kind of saying like he's this is uh
the tail end of the he might just be the
passion for it is not the same he's a
race him in himself as the as the
greatest of all time right so it's like
if you question mark
I saw the question mark faced the
greatest successful rapper of all well
when you say it he's the biggest
hitmaker so here's the thing about the
greatest of all time right it's like a
three-headed monster like it is a goat
we just heard some reference tracks that
kind of but I kind of just kind of just
made me look at that a little that
conversation a little bit since when was
the last time you go to River the
Clinton Miller thing Quinn Miller
2014. so I understand I understand I've
been in studios of rappers I get it
[__] get help with lines but
that was the whole song that's a fact
um but listen go ahead go ahead greatest
of all time
we didn't know that Jay-Z took 99
Problems from iced tea I didn't know
that
I didn't know that verse was from Bun B
I didn't know that okay I never heard
the song before
I knew the biggie references because we
heard the music but a lot of people if
you're from Memphis Tennessee you might
not even knew that bring them out bring
them out it's hard to yell when the
barrels in your mouth you might not know
that that's actually Biggie Smalls that
said that
I I knew it but like I'm saying so it's
like is that a reference track no no
it's not a reference track same thing
homage I'll say a big verse but how you
don't know it like I had no I just found
out two days ago that 99 Problems was
from iced tea I just found out a week
ago that that verse was from the not the
verse
of having a [__] but a [__] having no
goddamn sense trying to put that's a
reference that's a bar did you know that
I didn't know it
it's a
bars for saying Drake is the goat I get
it these numbers are on the boards
but there's only a few goats yeah how
many are there Drake Kanye Jay-Z Nas
Tupac Biggie Smalls Kendrick Lamar
I think it's too early I can't I can't
give I can't say it's too early
yes okay so biggie had two albums once
again you live alone wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait I'm not going
with it
big is a goat off of two albums two
albums you could really say three
because of the double album okay what
okay Kendrick
is it has to be a goat off of his body
at work already because there's an
argument now Kendrick's going
he has to be going the the argument of
it's too early in his career he dropped
passed away God forbid he passed away he
has Classics 10 years yes it's not like
he's not selling out shows every time he
doesn't it's not like he's putting up
putting out bodies of work Quality Music
like yeah he's good but I also look at
it like Kendrick to me is like Eminem oh
no well by the way Eminem's a goat You
Gotta Give It Away why you say it Like
That Eminem but Eminem has never sniffed
an album as good as Kendrick's best two
albums three albums I'm just saying as
far as like cultural influence right I
listen to good kid man see I listen to
pimp a butterfly but like I hang around
like some younger kids and the cultural
and we spoke about this with different
people
Kendrick the cultural influence is not
there maybe not a new I think in La it
is no I don't know
I don't disagree with you
no no I don't disagree with you in terms
of like
Kendrick might not have the cultural
influence that Future Has yeah or Drake
has future is another one he's a ghost I
agree I think he's a goat Futures ago
that's a lot of ghosts listen my top ten
they can't just be Legends he's golden
he's a legend
bro Future's like top five most
influential rapper ever I'm not arguing
yeah I'm just saying is he a ghost he's
golden but I'm just saying like like
when I say like I think he's I think I
think he's the greatest Club artist of
all time I think he has it I think he
has a classic I think dirty sprite 2 is
a classic album okay he's got classic I
think this his longevity is still he's
still going but I do think that
like Eminem never I never in life ever
listen to Eminem's music you never
listen to The Eminem Show I did I think
that's his best I never listen to it
it's not a lot in common
and then that mixtape era where he was
on all the Green Lanterns I think it was
Conway or somebody said like we don't
look like there's no disrespect all
right listen I've been in the car with
Conway in Denver Colorado
he was in the car and he was playing the
most random Eminem album cuts and I
filmed it because I was like
he went back to the Marshall Mathers
check out my guy actually listening to
Eminem like listen I'm just saying as
far as I think Jim Jones said this right
growing up
growing up like the people that I was
around right never in life ever played
Eminem's music so I think that like
influence culturally is
because Eminem definitely
undeniably had cultural influence maybe
not
in what code he didn't have he didn't
have no influence
no no I'm not I'm not saying he in I'm
not saying I mean he influenced pop
culture and America pop culture American
yes American culture he did not in like
nobody was like dressing like that go
check out this guy
Jordan sweatsuits
doing that but he opened up he opened
the door for a new audience he
he gave us 50
. he didn't give us he didn't give us 50
we had 50 Cent New York we had 50. y'all
had the mixtapes and he played a part in
it if he would have had his second wave
after the Colombian deal but yeah he
played a part major
I got the XXL behind you listen listen
came out
50 Cent was in a bidding war bro like
Wanksta was already done they they
mastered the rescue but the wing still
was done by
um who produced that record it wasn't it
wasn't
um it wasn't true no it was um what
should we call it his first person that
he was working with
from New York shot money yeah yo
wankster yeah by the time Winston came
out 50 Cent was already 50. no no and he
was listening he was going to be whoever
now listen the difference is is in the
club no no no no in the club is what
changed mainstream yes Main Street so
I'm saying 50 would have been like he
50. it could have been like Dipset and
Cameron we don't know and I'm not saying
Dipset I'm not trying to Discount
dipsetting shout out to the girls love
those guys I'm a huge [__] Dipset guy
but I I think we can all agree like
commercially like Sam was never like a
superstar no they didn't but they had
more cultural
G Unit they did they had way more
cultural disagree but I'm saying 50
we don't know what his ceiling would
have been without a Dr Dre Eminem cosign
no that's the fact that's fair that's a
fact and get rich or die trying that's
got Eminem and Dre's fingerprints all
over it but my lotto's records already
did but a lot of those wreck I mean the
biggest records were already there 21
Questions already there many men was
already there Langston was already there
in the club yes definitely dating in the
club wasn't heat produced by Dre
patiently waiting I don't think that's
one of his better records but he's crazy
no he's the one with the gunshot oh okay
okay in the beat I mean look they played
a major part in in making him a
mainstream artist for sure I just think
that like Eminem might not like as an
artist he doesn't have the cultural
influence as a Dipset exactly so this is
an interesting and like I said no
disrespect because those guys every
single person that we just named is a
legend Eminem's a legend but what I'm
saying is that mainstream success and
cultural influence are two different
things correct Eminem had tremendous
mainstream success he didn't have any
cultural influence there's no disrespect
I've never seen anybody say that they
want like Dipset didn't have mainstream
success they had tremendous yeah they
had tremendous cultural influence their
cultural influence way out surpassed the
amount of records that they sold I agree
like you know what I'm saying so there's
certain people that have strong cultural
influence and are not successful as far
as selling a bunch of records and then
some people that sell a bunch of records
and don't have cultural I just think
Eminem's cultural influence is different
so then where's Drake Drake because
what's the cultural interest rates
listen in the urban community I'm gonna
tell you because every Club in America
that you go to they playing Drake every
radio station they playing Drake
has it but that sounds like more amazing
no that's mainstream yeah so me and my
boy glasses Malone because G Malone says
this about Drake Drake what what's the
what's Drake's culture that he's
bringing to the table listen listen he's
bringing Toronto Canada let me let me
explain something to you I went to
Toronto Canada 15 years ago right before
before Drake nobody even knew who Drake
was it used to be ten dollars to get
into a club right they had no sense of
like how we was doing things as far as
bottle service and none of that with
none of that you go to him you go up
there and just because you was an
American you get treated like oh you're
royalty I came back after Drake
everything was changed it was a hundred
dollars can you tell me the cultural
influence here that he has because I've
never seen somebody try to dress like
Drake No he has no influence when it
comes to Fashion well what does he have
an influence on music he changed his
stream he no no no no no I'm saying as
far as Drake's influence is his like to
me ASAP Rocky has like cultural
influence right that like we can like on
a certain on a certain level
ASAP is the same thing with like a guy
like Tyler the Creator who's had
influenced culturally and and now also
the commercials coming around and now
he's had the dimension success where
it's like release hats with his whole
crew here's what I'm saying right
you could go to the Highlight Rule and
you're gonna hear Drake you could go to
Dyckman basketball tournament in New
York you're going to hit Drake you're
not gonna hit Eminem and Dyckman you're
not but
but
you're gonna hear
You're Gonna Hear T-Pain and everywhere
right t-pains he has influence he had
him he had influence on music The Main
Street how about this how about this how
about this you could go to like 30
different types of places in America
right now I'm not saying Dykeman I'm not
saying the bro I'm saying depending on
where you go in let's say 2012 you might
hear Flo Rida in like 12 spots right
what's gonna happen but
influence is not just all right we got
we gotta break down what does influence
really mean
part of influence is fashion like so you
got people rap like Drake
yes or does he is Drake sounded like
Drake he implemented he influenced a lot
of Dreams
same time is kind of he's really good at
sampling culture absolutely like one
album will be like I like the British
[__] let me just tap in and put gigs on
my [__] and then the other guy I'm gonna
do a house album we got to give him
credit for that because I love the fact
that he's he's turning up those but he's
has it and he's bringing new eyes to
that it's the same thing like he has the
Air Force he's bringing he is like yo I
like that sound let me incorporate that
sound number one because I like it but
number two Let Me highlight the people
that are doing it and it brings more
attention to that sound it's like and I
had this conversation before it was like
yo did we know who it was before he did
a song with him I don't disagree I think
Drake and now like you look at Whiskey
and it's like oh this guy is I just
think that but I'm the biggest artist
let's get back to this influence
conversation right there's different
types of influence so you got influence
of fashion okay so Kanye West is
probably the biggest influence when it
comes to Fashion he's influenced culture
when it comes to musician no no I'm just
saying just fashion for sure Dip set
influent fashion yeah right
um so there's different people that have
played major parts of influence Jay-Z at
one point influenced fashion Nas
influenced fashion early
yeah ASAP Rocky influence fashion to a
certain what was NASA's influence on
fashion that Raekwon wasn't already kind
of they were both
guys came out with the Ava wrecks you
guys were there yeah yeah so so first
are we giving are we giving Nas to abrax
leather jacket credit it's not it's not
when I think of it that's what I think I
think the Street Dreams remix Nas was
the flyest rapper yes so when he came
with the fade in the part that's hip-hop
culture that's fair enough the Army
jacket sneaker Uzi on the island in my
Army Jack and London Army jackets were a
New York staple for a very long period
of time he helped Pioneer that right
um Denny's then he got fly away it was
written when he started wearing the
leather coats and the Ava rexes and all
of that like those were those fashion
Billboards when we was watching the
videos like yo I got the [__] but they
all got fired around the same time right
so then then you see the pocket with
Versace and then you see big with
Versace and then you see Nas and that's
that same right they all started and
knives were more similar as far as their
dressers now big was more he was more
flamboyant and he was more like designer
you had to have a bag to dress like big
you can [__] around Versace shirts
so Drake's influences music but let's
let's so then then you got gang culture
okay that's influential
Dip set another date influenced gang
culture tremendously in New York there
was no gangs in New York now gang
culture is embedded in New York culture
and they played a major part not to say
that that's something that's positive
but it's influence yeah from Snoop Dogg
Nipsey Huss all of these guys influenced
gang culture right and they on the
masses from even Chief Keef in Chicago
right for sure all of that that's game
culture then you got influence as far as
actual music right so this is why I say
Drake Drake doesn't have any Street
influence he doesn't have any fashion
influence but his musical influence is
undeniable I even look at a little baby
I don't think anybody wants to dress
like little baby he doesn't have any
influence when it comes to Fashion he's
influenced when it comes to music is
like you're playing like anywhere I go
in America it could be Wisconsin it
could be Brooklyn it could be South
Central
I'ma hear his music being played I'm not
hearing Kendrick Lamar's music true I'm
not hearing Kendrick Lamar's music
criteria no because Eminem was not
influential in black neighborhoods
he I didn't nobody wanted to dress like
Eminem nobody would listen to Eminem
Eminem is the worst dresser
so Eminem was was they was listening to
him in middle of America but Eminem
influenced a lot of white kids to be
like oh it's okay for me to wear a durag
I wasn't one of them
he influenced pop culture and he
influenced American culture he
influenced medical that is culture
that's always my thing right hip-hop
culture is driven by black people I
agree yeah he didn't drop that's why I
said
never influenced Black Culture but you
say Eminem's Not a goat he is a goat
okay yeah but he's he's not he's guarded
as somebody who was tremendously
influential right because I I never
listened to him so the thing is like 50
would argue that right like he would
definitely say there's an argument
even if you give
um 10 of the 50 credit like hey you get
10 of why 50 is 50 for those that's a
hell of a question that's like Jimmy
Iovine right I mean the is yeah but it's
Leo cone that's like saying Leo that's
different dude I think it's just
different because we're talking about
Eminem's the biggest rapper in the world
hip-hop culture is American culture
right that's it right hip hop culture is
American culture and influenced American
culture right he might have brought more
eyes to it when I go to concerts when I
look it doesn't look like me when I go
to concerts right he might have brought
attention to it now fans are saying like
yo I'll listen to that I listen to this
person you got to give them credit for
that now as far as like people bumping
this [__] nah I didn't I listened I
listened to the Eminem show I thought it
was a great album but it's probably like
the last time I listened to like front
to back from them but I know he has
great songs I know he's a great great
business decision by the way yeah but I
mean he makes he made I mean Rihanna
joins on I think that was recovery yeah
uh yeah yeah recovery those are pretty
much the Way You Lie yeah those are good
songs right so I can't discount them and
say like he had no influence his last
album wasn't bad uh music could be
murdered by but actually is that when he
did the the rapping as the fastest that
was the one he had like juice World on
the comments because he's [__]
terrible he was he rapping like he had
the Guinness yeah Rap God was that was
not Kamikaze Rap God was uh Marshall
Mathers LP2 I believe like that takes
time to do yeah but it's also like
nobody wants to eat nobody's gonna
nobody's gonna recite that yeah it was
just like oh that was a good piece of
art that you did right yeah I don't know
man I think I think uh you know there's
a go I mean I gotta push a t in my top
like eight so he's in top eight but my
personal list yeah not in like the
all-time plus uh [__] I got it let's see
Lord willing which is a great I think
that might be a classic yeah I would say
it's Nas
yay
nausea Hove Hove to me is like the
Undisputed greatest of all time that
like if like I just think like if if I'm
gonna put the real list together he's I
think the only one I can challenge Hove
is Drake and Kanye was the only thing
with Kanye is like Kanye to me when I
put like the MC glasses on it's a little
fuzzy because I think it really doesn't
right that was nice he gets a lot of uh
that was a little yeah a whole lot but
to me I think Kanye is the greatest
artist of all time personally I think
he's got the best discography I think if
I'm like if I had to go on an island
with one guy's that's out of your work
it'd be yeah
um but yeah I I would go Nas
Oh yay Andre
Kendrick
ghost face
where's my personal list off the top of
my head by the way Pusha T's up there
Rick Ross is around 10. comment for me's
up there I love common
I just think he had like a twanga
um you say Drake he did not say not in
my personal no no I got Freddie Gibbs
like a real high on my personal [__] I
think um fit I mean Freddy ever
just for my personal like I think like
for me like I think Alfredo he's got to
me to me three Classic Albums the pinata
that's just me though okay I've never
listened to the music you got to listen
to Alfredo fully produced by now you
know so you know what's so crazy about
this Freddie gay situation you know the
only Freddie Gibbs song I ever heard in
my life what the song he has with Benny
the butcher oh well it's actually a very
good song great song it'll never happen
again it probably won't perform that
probably not well Benny still performs
it because it's his biggest song it's
his biggest one yeah is it not the
jungle cold now uh that probably is yeah
uh I think one-way flight is now it's
got to be a second biggest song he still
performs it sucks because I'm tight with
both of them it's a hell of a record and
we see Benny all the time Benny's my God
no I love it his That's a classic That's
a classic that's that album yes
and he doesn't have a uh uh Benny
doesn't have it out he's got to mix it
up you're terrible boy yeah who did I
say yeah Alchemist hippo yeah listen to
him Freddy gives Alfredo that's the name
of it yeah two or three years ago
Alfredo yeah I mean that's the one he
got nominated for a Grammy for great
great body of work yeah I mean I think
but then if I can put together z-list is
different because I'm like it's Jay-Z
Drake is in there
I got little Wayne real low on my [__]
though I never listen like low as far as
what like in the top five I think Lil
Wayne
and I love it's my God this is I'm just
letting you know this is my guy no this
is my guy I said 1996 The Carter too I
actually think my personal favorite I
like the first card or the most yeah for
me
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our good Folks at Blue chew
baby that's right A lot of people keep
asking me does Bluetooth work [__] yeah
it does and if you don't believe me
they'll give you a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg that's
bootry.com promo code bootleg you get a
month of blue chew for free delivered to
your [__] house all you do is pay
five dollars in shipping what is blue
tree you ask well let me tell you it has
the same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable tablet but it is
discreetly delivered right to your
doorstep no awkward doctor's visits
imagine going and telling uh an old guy
about your dick
you would prefer not to do that I know
I'd prefer not to do that you know but
you could do it all online bluetooth.com
you don't have to go to the doctor's
appointment in person no more no they're
going to send it straight to your door
all right your wife won't even know it
came your wife won't know
that you came and it came all right so
what you do is
you uh you go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg and you get a month
of uh the whole thing for free that's
right a month supply of Bluetooth for
free straight to your door they also
just dropped their new mint chewable
which is the same exact active
ingredient as Levitra so many options
for you at Bluetooth to make sure your
dick is right going into the springtime
baby look spring break's coming uh are
you gonna be coming
the real question is
is your partner gonna be coming
not with the noodle dick
let's be honest make sure that shit's
hard as [__]
go to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg and get a month supply for free
and if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it's okay man
it happens to the best of us go to
Bluetooth and put a Band-Aid on that
thing bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
also
while we're talking about our partners
shout out to our family at Odd Socks oh
look at these Odd Socks underwear man
they're they're Half Baked
so much going on at Odd Socks uh so many
dope licenses man shout out to uh they
got Cheetos they got Jaws [__] Oreos
Cheech and Chong Naruto WWE by the way
WrestleMania is coming I can't wait to
see what dope WrestleMania socks they do
this year because last year they knocked
it out the park at Odd Socks look the
most comfortable socks in the world they
got The Odd Socks Basics that you need
on your feet uh all you gotta do is go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg at checkout
you'll save 20 off your total order
underwear socks
[__] hats whatever you need they got it
at Odd Socks uh they just got the
Coca-Cola deal so you go get some
Coca-Cola drawers Coca-Cola socks so
much always going on in Odd Socks I'm
gonna always say my favorites are the
WWE in the Breaking Bad Ones
um so go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you will
save 20 off at checkout shout out to
them most comfortable socks in the world
crazy comfortable underwear my goodness
if you ain't got Odd Socks on your feet
and ass what are you doing out in these
streets all right go to
hotsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off let's get back to the
interview
I think he might be the most overrated
rapper ever
here's my thing
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
allow me to say I think he's one of them
okay you know what
Tupac's the most overrated rapper
he went deeper with the Dig yeah he took
it there deeper with the dead no no to
me Little Wayne for me when I think of
Wayne I think that
he's just put out a lot of [__]
in the same way that I think of Eminem
Like Eminem's put out so much terrible
[__] subpar music
he's put out so much trash that we just
don't even think about this window
okay the last time he put out anything
that was great was the first Oh No song
listen wait wait
the last time Little Wayne put some [__]
out that I was like yeah Wayne's that
[__] was No Ceilings and that
was an 0-9 the car was [__] trash
there's good records on the car yeah
there's like two good songs
and and guess what the best rapping on
that album was on the interludes when it
was like
six foot seven okay but also okay okay
okay fine great record but that being
said Carter Ford can go right in the
[__] recycle bin okay now we're not
gonna do it has great records Carter
Five I'll I'll give Carter you're
forgetting I Am Not a Human Being and
the [__] Rock album no no no no no
no because we still got great records on
no no you got what Drop the World with
Eminem Drop the World it's not I don't
think that's a great record but you got
this right no right above it's on that
with Drake
that's a great record it's right above
it I like that song There's a great
intro to that HBO show that the rock
stars that's a fact that licensing and
they licensed that too listen that has
great records you got not only wait wait
wait we're not gonna do this to win
right we're not wait this is my and
we're not gonna act like 500 Degrees was
good are we no we're not counting that
song are we gonna go because I like The
Block is Hot The Block is Hot is great
The Carter one is is lights out Carter 2
like I said is in my top five I think
all the time Carter three is so are you
starting Lil Wayne's career at the first
Carter no I'm starting with the Block is
Hot because that's one of them is hot
was great yeah lights out was whatever
the 100 degrees was [__] terrible
there was a phase okay Carter one was
great changed it Carter two we already
know cemented Carter three classic
do find it interesting by the way the
new song he dropped with the DMX sample
the Swiss beats largest is fire I love
it but what about the Lord don't you
just deal with a couple five four three
two one that's a great
song
the verse he did with Nikki and Drake he
killed that no I for sure because he's
still putting out good let me let me
verses and Good Records he hasn't
probably put out here look at his like
let me say Let me say something about
this because he's been here since he was
16. you bring up and now he's 41 and now
you can critique him you bring up a good
point but anyway everybody this is why
we gotta appreciate Park even though he
well he's not the best Lyricist it's
like for me everybody's different for me
as a rapper Pockets but but
influentially but but look let me let me
Lyricist but I think pox probably top
two most influential he's probably
number one but him the thing the thing
about it is um
this for me personally right and this is
I put Eminem
Lil Wayne
and a variety of other artists in the
same category where they're very
talented and they're they're extremely
up there with pockets but but let's say
this though for me right music Growing
Up music used to help me get through my
day right and it was education so like
some of the my favorite rappers are like
AZ and like these are things like and I
listen to what he's saying and the [__]
that he's talking about is real [__]
like it's it's actually education like
I'm learning things I'm hearing things
I'm like I don't know what that word
means he's rapping about real [__] right
so when I hear rappers like
a little baby no little babies rapping
about real [__] that's what I'm trying
to tell you little baby is nostalgic
from the 90s perspective when he when
he's saying like these [__] that he's
talking about he's actually rapping like
he's I think little baby is the most
improved rapper we've ever seen in real
time
he's saying like little baby is really
rapping real lyrics that's coming out of
his mouth my that my thing with Lil
Wayne has always been I don't what are
you rapping about I got six bathrooms I
could [__] all day like you always use
that line bro I'm just saying like you
act like that's the only line what I'm
just saying like you rapping about
things plenty of guys who have is that's
why like that's why I like TI right
because when TI was rapping it was real
[__] like I could understand the words
that he's saying it makes sense to me
he's telling a story I'm getting it you
know who also really ain't rapping about
[__] it's Drake No Drake's rapping about
[__] bro what is he rapping about
besides [__] that's okay that's it
that's it that's it that's it but it's
but it's still it's still it's still at
least he's rapping about something okay
like Eminem and Wayne I miss my dog they
just they they rapping they rap 48 bars
they haven't wrapped anything I said Lil
Wayne has Lil Wayne has such an insane
amount of Music out that it'd be unfair
to us to say he doesn't rap about it
that's what I'm saying as far as you
guys go back to the Carter four right
love is on that on that album right is
he not talking about
like a real situation that's real ass
[__] you could you could take that one
line I could take I could listen to now
and say yo doctor knock boot wasn't
probably the best song
that's a bad reference that's a bad
reference
you could find a bar that's like oh why
do you say that listen I look listen I
have to say I love Lil Wayne I'm a fan
of like a lot of Lil Wayne music like
almost like
I feel like dying is my [__] but that's
some that's some that's a mixtape [__]
mixtape Wing it's it's incredible but I
just we just had albums but I just think
like when I think of Wayne and the way
he's regarded I just don't know go if
the quality
overall lines up with someone like
Kendrick Lamar
or Jay-Z and it goes back what you
rapping about what are you rapping about
even like like I think of like DMX who
maybe wasn't like I kind of look at X in
the same way that I look at POC it was
more about the delivery the content how
it made you feel you know what I'm
saying like DMX and Tupac are two of the
greatest of all time even though I I
said what I said about Bach but I just
like when I think of little Wayne I
don't know what time when Lil Wayne has
ever made me feel like [__] I think of a
Time Jay-Z he's made me feel that way I
think of a Time Jake holds made me feel
that and I don't you know J Cole's
another one J Cole's up there is he a
girl he's up there he's another one who
doesn't have a consensus classic even
though Forest Hills Drive is a classic
to me and a lot of people but the [__]
that he's rapping about I agree he's up
there like the fact he did a whole album
about like [__] people like this
whole drug [__] going on that 1984
whatever
that song I love y'all that dude's
different yeah
for sure and for what it's worth this is
a crazy statement to make
but I've seen when Cole was touring
whatever album that was at the time
well 2016. so it wasn't it was the one
that had Neighbors on it
uh Your Eyes Only I think yeah that's
yeah yeah I hated that album but when he
was Touring that album at the same time
Kendrick was torn Dan
I went to I went to both in L.A
and J Cole
I'm telling you man somebody came out
with the prison suit he was in the
middle of the I think they was
they were so happy I went to both shows
and I feel like the energy at the coal
La show was like 10 times crazy in the
Kendrick [__] that's crazy we just
talking about that show yeah that was a
he put on a great performance everything
looked good it you can feel it the
passion was there it was like yo he has
records that belong in arenas in along
the stadium
country has that too yeah but he's
mastered now the stage presence like
this last tour Kendrick like he just
took it to a different level
it was like only only like we only seen
like Drake does it now because he has
the money to to have all the the Pyro
and have all the like oh yeah it's crazy
Drake had that like basketball yeah the
3D court and all that like he has a
money now it didn't start that way but
like the first person I ever see do that
was yay for sure before he even had the
capital to do it and that's the crazy
thing we think about yay's influence how
how is it influenced live shows he had
to it when I went to the
glow-in-the-dark tour I went to Kanye's
first tour Rihanna opened I was there I
went to Usher's confession store and
Drake No so that's his first tour it was
the opening act Yes actually so my best
friend's brother like my childhood best
friend's brother is in a group called
Dilated Peoples so Dilated Peoples had a
song with Kanye called this way but they
also opened The College Dropout tour so
I actually went as like a 15 year old
kid yeah went to like for the dates when
came out here to L.A went to the House
of Blues twice and then when he came to
Phoenix uh I got to meet Kanye backstage
but
that show was did you go to The College
Dropout show I didn't confessions was
the professionals first time CLC a
consequence do a spaceship live and he
had the hip-hop violinist chick out
there and John Legend was just up there
just on stage just [__] like no one
cared like I'm telling you go in the
dark that's when it was like this guy's
different yeah he's different and now
you can see when you look at Trav and he
got the roller coaster going through the
crowd and like he changed it then he had
to float and Stage for the saint Pablo
and I was like crazy no this is the
greatest thing ever I still haven't seen
a show that was better than that show
but he's floating and I'm like that's
art and now the guys are doing it
they're seeing it and like all right we
can take pieces of that in our own way
and be creative with it a lot of it is
the stage but it's like let's get back
to bars this is why I like being a
butcher it's real [__] he's rap he's
real rap
nipsy hustle is nostalgic to the era
that I grew up on where he's rapping
about things that are relatable they're
understandable he's coherent when he
speaks
this is something that's important in
rap music a lot of these rappers are not
that and when we talk about the greatest
of all time you gotta have that as a
component because it's like you could be
a great rapper but what are you rapping
about I think Wayne is one of the
greatest of all time but he's to me he's
not in the top ten
and I think everybody who talks about
Wayne thinks he's like number one I
think Wayne and Kobe are kind of the
same God Rest Kobe soul
like Kobe fans and Little Wayne fans are
very similar this guy's going for it
he's just you guys are basketball fans
no no what I'm about to say is a fact
listen if you talk to somebody who loves
Kobe he's the greatest basketball player
of all time he's the goat or he's the
closest thing to Jordan because they did
they jaded they're jaded and also they
don't watch a lot of basketball okay so
if we're it's like they're like where he
really is is like seven or eight maybe
maybe not even that he might there's a
lot of Publications that don't have Kobe
in the top ten but but like at best he's
like seventh all time probably like
probably that's probably and to me
that's like great it's still a
tremendous Kobe Bryant over [__]
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar listen when you
start or even Tim Duncan nah I'm putting
over when you say I'm one thousand
percent rings two different dynasties on
the same team yeah Kobe's in two
different dynasties and has five rings
when you say that when you say that it's
a fact made it work with Manu model's a
Hall of Famer I mean
David Robinson's in the Hall of Fame
no no no no
where'd he win his first shoot it was
the uh the lockout year and who was on
the team David Robinson who was the best
player on the team Tim Duncan this is my
thing with Coach rest in peace God bless
God I got him right there God bless I
love Kobe Mamba mentality forever you
weren't the best player on the team bro
when on free Shaq bro three times three
times it would be the best play on the
final this is what I would like to point
out about Kobe he was the best player on
the final the last LeBron was always the
best player can we point out something
specific every single wait wait wait
wait a minute oh wait a minute
they're [__] insane and I would like
to point out okay Shaquille O'Neal
leaves gets a ring with D Wade in Miami
this carry gets carried touring what was
going on with the Lakers at that time
they were scratching into the playoffs
there's eight seeds and getting bounced
out by my Phoenix Suns in round one he
got quite what a charge that derailed
three years in a row
okay okay so then then I'd like to
Circle let's Circle back no disrespect
to those guys two yeah
LeBron yeah
who got to the finals in 07 the best I'd
ever do this [__] man LeBron he's the
guy he's the best I have a [__]
LeBron James toy right there
got to the finals in 07. who was on his
team
Mo Williams All-Star
what he he didn't make an All-Star team
that's it he didn't win
listen listen we're not with this is
what we knock on it okay look that was
the worst team outside of Illinois
outside of Allen Iverson that was the
worst team ever to make an NBA tonight
they beat the defending NBA champions in
the Eastern Conference Finals
act like LeBron to have a terrible cast
of characters
you could debate that or we could just
say facts was more Williams an All-Star
oh God
they're all stars right I'm just saying
who's the other big man in the East I'm
just saying that Wallace
they had that too big man yo I'm just
saying the tea was terrible the team was
just saying that those guys are
All-Stars right Allen Iverson worse now
you go back to that liquor team and you
tell me the second best player
what what Laker team the ones he's
talking about they went to the finals no
no no the team's winning exactly they go
to the finals I'm telling you to name me
the next best player he had a he had
LeBron James they have a good team tell
me the next best player let's look
I'll tell you right now
2006.07 they were 42 and 40 and I think
they were the eight seed so this is
where this is when they lost to the
number one C Suns correct the Phoenix
Suns of of uh Tim Thomas okay okay wait
a minute Tim Thomas is on that team you
wanna know who's on the team in 06 yeah
Andrew Bynum was in Austin not so fat
that's a fact he's the first browser
he's the first draft okay okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait did we
agree he was not also he's the first
pick can we agree at the very least
first pick and what can we agree what
are you talking about can we agree that
one of the greatest
role players in six men of all time
before crack hit him was Lamar Odom
that's a fact because he was on the team
that's a fact
anybody on that on that Cavalier team
that's a fact Lamar better than anybody
else
here I saw LeBron keep going fact I
can't look it it's again it does get bad
you got [__]
who was starting
that's the starting guard but look at
LeBron Chris Mims is the starting center
if you're not Andrew if you're supposed
to be better than LeBron get out of the
[__] first round if you're supposed
to be betting LeBron win a championship
and he did that in 09 and 10 and he lost
you know because Jerry West served him
up Paul [__] Gasol in a [__] plate
no the NBA did a disservice by not
letting them have Chris Paul and that's
how they got power console because they
felt bad and Jerry and they should have
done that right how do you how do you
say yeah you can't trade them too I love
Kobe yeah Kobe too yeah I love Kobe Tim
Duncan's better he's not better
no no no Tim Duncan you want to talk
about influence Tim Duncan has can we
talk about zero Tim Duncan beat in the
finals Tim Duncan is the worst dressed
NBA player of all time oh yeah it's a
worst Gene no yeah he is he's worse than
Jordan but Jordan's jeans can we have
um
but Tim Duncan was sandals bro yeah he
never he never tried the people who
cares exactly that's what I'm saying
he's just the words he's still a hell of
a player yeah no he's a Hall of Famer
he's probably top 10 he's just not ahead
of Cobra I believe top ten yeah probably
impeccable his career is something
impeccable
before Tim Duncan came along it was Carl
Malone
I mean he [__] 12 year old you know
what I mean
I'm so surprised by the way the fact
that they had that other verb they're
judging the dunk contest what all he did
was it anyway
what is what is next for earn your
leisure when does this come out uh
probably Wednesday of next week so we
got a big show in La you guys invited if
you want to come watch the live show
Noble theater March 11th March 11th
congrats appreciate you Market Monday's
live we're gonna bring out a lot of
surprises I got you guys got to complete
me with the with the investor guy you
guys do Market Mondays with yeah yeah
he's gonna be this he's out here right
now yeah for sure he's gonna be at the
show so Market we got a lot so we're
doing a world tour actually for Market
Mondays and the first stop is La after
La we go to Toronto then we go to London
then we go to Chicago then we go to
Ghana so wow that's dope man yeah so
it's a live show and all live shows are
different it's not like a seminar like
it's entertainment it's theatrics his
education is all of it's a Vibe like
people wearing their best clothes like
it's dope you're gonna see a mixture of
it all right so no vote theater uh March
11th dope and then you know we got a
bunch of different stuff we cooking up
invest Fest we we um we working on that
we're gonna announce details on that
that's our financial literacy Festival
that's a big big big thing that we do in
Atlanta every year so this year is going
to be even bigger than it was last year
last year we had Tyler Perry Steve
Harvey you got 14 000 people so they
should be looking for twenty thousand
that's huge yeah it's gonna be crazy
yeah three thousand fourteen thousand
twenty thousand and then you know just
just a bunch of other things man content
more content
um more ways to you know expand on the
education we have a podcast Network so
early just a media company we have we
produce podcast stuff you guys have
podcasts Under the Umbrella yeah seven
shows on the umbrella they're all doing
well
um so yeah man just just look into just
to keep expanding who do you guys want
to interview that you haven't
interviewed yet in terms of I mean
obviously we know you want to interview
Drake and you want to interview Little
Wayne but I mean I mean in terms that
you guys think you could have some like
I think the Ross interview was
incredible because you guys kind of went
over some of the franchise [__] and I
think you know you and the Russell made
a lot of sense in terms of like what you
all do who's somebody you guys really
want to talk to uh I always say and I'll
say until he sits next to us and
nothing's gonna happen Sean Carter I
think Jay-Z makes a lot of sense of
sports um I think that's the one right
yeah just from a standpoint of where we
started especially you know writing
financial literacy lesson plans it
started with him
um and that line that he had in
Reasonable Doubt which is his first
album obviously all black Scotty sports
and entertainment until even and so just
just pulling that line up apart and
dissecting it and really like seeing
like wait let's try to debunk this let's
try to show value in other different
ways outside of those two things to show
that we can be anything we really want
if we had the education and the
resources around it
just having him there from that line to
this I think definitely my number one
that would be crazy yeah I think you
know just think on a bigger scale
possible Elon Musk Jeff Bezos aliko
dangote who's the richest black person
in the world out of Nigeria
um Warren Buffett the musk thing Could
Happen Elon Musk I think it definitely
could happen I feel like it's just about
you know him being aware of it in the
right space it's like Kanye I feel like
you'll do anything if it just defended
how he wakes up in the morning like you
know what I mean but the Elon I think
that'll break the internet did you guys
like uh do you like I mean
what do you guys feel about Twitter
since he's taken over
um I was never really huge on Twitter
um I appreciate Twitter because it's
like you just go in there and just say
your random thoughts and get off like it
doesn't I use it for like sports news
and like random [__] it's not it's not
as addictive as Instagram for me right
so I appreciate Twitter I think you know
I don't see anything bad I just feel
like elon's like we're just kind of like
watching the trial and era of like this
really rich dude just we'll figure this
thing out firing 80 of the staff and
then figuring it out on the fly so it's
kind of cool it's like to me it's like
kind of cool to be like this
[__] so rich he's just using
this [__] as like yeah that's another
asset and then it'll be a private
company and it'll be you know we'll
we'll figure out what he does with it
but it's a place for people to it's a
new form of news for a generation right
like we used to have to I used to read
the newspaper right well I used to watch
the news and now it's like people just
go to their phone it's like oh no tweet
something just happened in the world
right I mean
that'll be big though last question
let's say someone's got 10 grand saved
up you guys have covered a bunch of
Industries on your show whether it's the
vending machine hustle or the trucking
[__] or there's so many ways people can
get money if you guys were talking to
somebody who had ten thousand dollars of
like
not that's not all the money they have
but they got 10 grand to start a
business with or to try to invest or how
would you suggest them
what would what would you have them do
with that 10 grand if you're advising
the first thing is to formulate a plan
before you just really think about what
you want to do right because you could
do vending machines you can buy some
stock you can depending on what part of
the country and then you could
potentially buy real estate but
it's going to be hard to do anything
successful if you don't really have a
plan in place so I would say before you
do anything educate yourself sit down
with a pen and paper and physically
write out a plan of like what you think
is your best option and then from there
like I said you could do either one of
those things um but like you can always
invest in stocks with very low amount of
money you can invest in stocks with
thousand dollars so if you want to just
put now you're not going to turn that
ten thousand to a million right
um but at least it'll be working for you
over the course of time if you want to
start a business like I said some local
some low costing businesses you have
mentioned vending machines you can
definitely start that business for under
ten thousand dollars so you guys say you
got uh five at your school you went to
yeah yeah five it's pretty profitable
too I think it brings in like 3 500 a
month something like that that's great
yeah that's crazy yeah it's one of those
things man it was like there was an
opportunity there it's something that we
know it was needed the school didn't
have any you guys just hire someone to
go refill it things right there
he runs the vending machine business for
us but it was a great way to give back
to our school you know we didn't see
anybody doing anything like that and
right the best part is that we give a
percentage of every month of the revenue
we give back to the senior class wow so
when we talk about economic hardship how
do we combat it well what happens if we
can subsidize what the Prime cost was or
what the yearbook was or senior dues
give money to the senior class so they
don't need to have bake sales or they
don't have to have these Raffles right
they're actually creating their own
economy the kids that are in the school
spend money in the vending machines and
everybody's going to be a senior at some
point and so everybody benefits I still
man well I appreciate y'all pulling up
thank you for having us brother
appreciate it March 11th Lenovo
go to Ernie alicia.com under the market
Monday's World Tour Tab and if you're in
La Southern California or the West Coast
period
um it's our first time we're ever doing
a show because we've done shows all
around the world New York London
um all over but this is our first time
ever doing the show in LA on the West
Coast period so that's a huge uh that's
a dope venue legendary venue yeah we
have the verses we got the verses there
um it was uh it was Ray J and Omarion
versus uh Sammy and uh Mario that was an
undercard but it was Mario versus
it was Mario versus omario I always tell
everybody that that was the r b version
of The Dip set box joint because I think
a lot of people were like Dipset Dip set
yeah it was like no you knew you you go
on you went in think of Mario the whole
time no no oh I didn't think that but I
think that what happened was Omarion has
definitively more hits than Mario but
Mario actually sang yeah better
performer he performed he's saying his
heart out and like Omarion was eating
watermelon no people knew
he did that
I couldn't I couldn't even [__]
believe it
and he's in he's from L.A wearing Tim's
in L.A I'm like What's Happening Here
it's interesting but we will find we
were front row for that Dipset locks
battle that was [__] crazy
legendary yeah well look uh the 11th
Novo yeah watch the podcast how many uh
Market Mondays on Monday how many like
pieces of content you guys usually drop
it in a month uh well Market Mondays
comes out every Monday that's four
hernia Leisure comes out every Tuesday
so at least eight yeah and then you guys
clip everything and yep there it is at
the minimum appreciate y'all pulling up
a big fan of you guys man thank you man
appreciate it appreciate you